what I want to do in this video is a few
examples that test our intuition of the
derivative as a rate of change or the
steepness of a curve or the slope of a
curve or the slope of a tangent line of
a curve depending on how you actually
want to think about it so here it says f
prime of 5 so this notation prime this
is another way of saying well what's the
derivative let's estimate the derivative
of our function at 5 and when we say F
prime of 5 this is the slope slope of
tangent line tangent line at 5 or you
could view it as the you could view it
as the rate of change of Y with respect
to X which is really how we define slope
respect to X of our function f so let's
think about that a little bit we see
they put the point the point 5 comma F
of 5 right over here and so if we want
to estimate the slope of the tangent
line if we want to estimate the
steepness of this curve we could try to
draw a line that is tangent right at
that point and so let me see if I can do
that so if I were to draw a line
starting there if I just wanted to make
it tangent it looks like it would do
something like that that right at that
point that looks to be about how steep
that curve is now what makes this an
interesting thing and nonlinear is that
it's constantly changing changing the
steepness it's very low here and it gets
steeper and steeper and steeper as we
move to the right for larger and larger
X values but if we look at the point in
question when X is equal to 5 remember F
prime of 5 would be if we were
estimating it this would be the slope of
this line here and the slope of this
line it looks like for every time we
move one in the X direction we're moving
two in the Y direction Delta Y is equal
to two when Delta X is equal to one so
our change in Y with
respect to X at least for this tangent
line here which would represent our
change in Y with respect to X right at
that point is going to be equal to 2
over 1 or 2 and they told us to estimate
it but all of these are way off having a
negative 2 derivative would mean that as
we increase our X are Y is decreasing so
if our curve looks something like this
we would have a slope of negative 2 if
having having slopes in this a positive
of 0.1 that would be very flat something
down here we might have a slope closer
to point 1 negative point 1 that might
be closer on this side whereas downward
sloping but very close to flat a slope
of 0 that would be right over here at
the bottom where right at that moment as
we change X Y is not increasing or
decreasing the slope of the tangent line
right at that bottom point would have a
slope of 0 so I feel really good about
that response let's do one more of these
so all right so they're telling us to
compare the derivative of G at 4 to the
derivative of G at 6 and which one of
these is greater and like always pause
the video and see if you could figure
this out
well this is just an exercise let's see
if we were to if we were to make a line
that indicates the slope there you could
view this as a tangent line so let me
try to do that so that wouldn't that
that's an do a good job so right over
here at so that looks like a pretty I
think I can do a better job than that
now that's too shallow let's see not
shallows number that's too flat so let
me try to really okay that looks pretty
good so that line that I just drew seems
to be indicative of the rate of change
of Y with respect to X or the slope of
that curve or at that line you could
view it as a tangent line so that we can
think about what its slope is going to
be and if we go further down over here
this one is it looks like it is steeper
but in the negative direction so it
looks like it is
it is steeper for sure but it's in the
negative direction as we increase think
of it this way as we increase X 1 here
it looks like we are decreasing Y by
about 1 so it looks like G prime of 4 G
prime of 4 the derivative when X is
equal to 4 is approximately I'm
estimating it negative 1 while the
derivative here when we increase X if we
increase X by if we increase X by 1 it
looks like we're decreasing Y by close
to 3 so G prime of 6 looks like it's
closer to negative 3 so which one of
these is is larger well this one is less
negative so it's going to be greater
than the other one
and you could have done this intuitively
if you just look at the curve this is
some type of a sinusoidal curve is flat
it's you have right at that moment they
have no change in Y with respect to X
then it starts to decrease at a phat and
then it decreases it even faster rate
then it decreases as a faster rate then
it starts is still decreasing but it's
decreasing at slower and slower rates
decreasing it's lower rates and right at
that moment it's not you have your slope
of your tangent line is 0 then it starts
to increase increase so on and so forth
and it just keeps happening over and
over again so you could also think about
this in a more intuitive way